for the independent self-consciousness
it is only the pure abstraction of the
eye that is its essential nature and
when it does develop its own differences
this differentiation has not become a
nature that is objective and intrinsic
to it
thus this self-consciousness does not
become an eye that it's in its
simplicity is genuinely self
differentiating or then in this absolute
differentiation remains identical with
it on the other hand the consciousness
that is forced back into itself becomes
in its formative activity its own object
in the form of the thing it is fashioned
and at the same time sees in the Lord a
consciousness that exists as a being for
self but for the subservient
consciousness as such these two moments
itself as an independent object in this
object as a mode of consciousness and
hence its own essential nature fall
apart since however the form and the
beating for self are for us or in
themselves the same and since in the
notion of independent consciousness the
intrinsic being his consciousness the
moment of the intrinsic being or thing
hood which received its form and being
fashioned is no other substance than
consciousness we are in the presence of
self consciousness in a new shape the
consciousness which as the infinitude of
consciousness or as it's pure movement
is aware of itself is essential being a
being which thinks were is a free self
consciousness for the thing does not
mean to be an abstract eye but an eye
which has at the same time the
significance of intrinsic being of
having itself for object or relating
itself to objective being in such a way
that it's significance is the being for
self of the consciousness for which it
is an object for in a thinking the
object is not presented self in picture
thoughts but any notions that is in a
distinct being in itself or intrinsic
being consciousness being immediately
aware that this is not anything distinct
from itself
what is pictured or figuratively
conceived what immediately is has as
such the form of being something other
than consciousness but a notion is also
something that immediately is and this
distinction
far as it is present in consciousness
itself is its determinate content but
since this content is at the same time a
content grasped in thought consciousness
remains immediately aware of its unity
with this determinate and distinct being
not as in the case of a picture thought
where consciousness still has specially
to bear in mind that this is its picture
thought on the contrary the notion is
for me straight away my notion in
thinking I am free because I am NOT in
an other but remain simply and solely in
communing with myself and the object
which is for me the essential being is
an undivided unity my being for myself
and my activity and conceptual thinking
is a movement within myself it is
essential however in thus characterized
in the shape of self consciousness to
bear firmly in mind that it is thinking
consciousness in general that its object
is an immediate unity of being in itself
and being for itself the self same
consciousness that repels itself from
itself becomes aware of itself and is
the element of being in itself but at
first it knows itself to be this element
only as a universal mode of being in
general now does it exist subjectively
in the development and process of its
manifold being
paragraph 197 now picks up in this last
section of the self-consciousness part
of the work after the master-slave
dialectic asking well where do we go
from here and the answer is pretty much
everywhere although much of that is
going to happen in the later sections
this is a very short section in
comparison to reason and spirit or even
the religion section and absolute
knowing that are going to come after
that so what we've got here in the
remainder of the consciousness or the
self consciousness section is Hegel
working his way through that that
question of that answer what happens
after the master-slave dialectic this is
not a historical question just about
what happens after slavery is instituted
and we move a little bit past it perhaps
reacting to the problematics that are
raised by the fact that slavery takes
self conscious beings and forces them
into the role of objects or property
it's not just a historical question like
that it's more in question about the
development of human consciousness as
what angles going to call an essential
being as a being that is able to
actually graph essences as part of its
essentiality so he's going to begin by
talking about stoicism not in this
paragraph as such you're not going to
see the word stoic up here you will see
that immediately show up after we move
into the next paragraphs and he's not
going to talk about stoicism that long
then he's going to talk about skepticism
as another you know it's a philosophical
school that arises in antiquity but it's
also something that ends up pervading
culture one can be a skeptic or a stoic
without ever having heard of skepticism
or stoicism and then there's going to be
a much longer discussion of what he
calls the unhappy consciousness and in
their own way both stoicism and
skepticism are unhappy forms of
consciousness as we're going to see
ironically because they're both aiming
at and happiness but I'm going to be
aiming for happiness
most when we don't possess it it becomes
something Thema tangible for us when
it's something that we need to think out
how to pursue and this this idea about
thinking is going to be really core as
well particularly for skepticism and for
what we're going to look at now
stoicism so what I've got here
diagram doubt for us we're beginning
from where independent
self-consciousness has gotten itself -
and these are two core dimensions of it
and then the the second dimension
recognizable is the slave is going to
have this relationship that we've just
spent a lot of time going through and
talking about how the slave is really
the one with whom the historical
initiative of consciousness you know is
going to unfold itself and it does so
through you know the relationship to the
master in fear and in service and the
working upon the object we've gone
through all that so we don't need to
rehearse that too much as we go into
this section but that is part of what
we're doing and now we're going to move
to what Google calls a new shape of
consciousness a new Gestalt
interestingly I'd like to point out and
we'll come back to this in this section
this is a section in which he's going to
use Gestalt first to talk about shape of
consciousness good thing right we're
moving on and then he's going to
contrast um you know representation
whether in the form of force jell-o or
Gestalt the Miller translation has a
picture language I believe or picture
thinking yeah
and that's actually a sort of loose
rendering for Chanel or Gestalt in here
so he's using Gestalt also in a not
quite pejorative way but in a way to say
look this isn't as good as it's going to
get in comparison to concept or notion
that is good so we'll come back to that
in a moment so let's look at the text
now directly for the independent self
consciousness the the slave the one who
has actually managed to get through all
of this stuff right and become a winner
of himself or herself
he has independent self consciousness it
is only the pure abstraction
the eye that is it's essential nature
the the transcending possibility of
negating all the determinacy and saying
something more this is something core to
human freedom this is something core to
human self-identity this is something
core to understanding the way in which
we are able to put ourselves out of our
immediate environment and think in flux
of ways so he says when it does develop
its own differences this differentiation
does not become a nature that is
objective and intrinsic to it
thus this self-consciousness does not
become an eye that it's in its
simplicity is genuinely self
differentiating it's always a good thing
for Hegel right over then in this
absolute differentiation remains
identical with itself so if we try to go
straight ahead and cut through all the
nonsense I just want the transcendental
unity of that perception or something
like that Hegel says look that's not
going to work for you you don't get what
I have worked through up to this point a
thing that is both what it is and also
you know others itself and then exists
in the relation to that you're not going
to get that out of any sort of static
conception or purifying we might come up
color to purifying by stripping away and
abstracting conception of the pure I
what about the other part it says on the
other hand the consciousness that is
forced back into itself becomes in its
formative activity its own object in the
form of the thing it has fashioned this
is what we saw in the master-slave
dialectic right the slave the servant by
being put to work not just at one point
in time not just in a sort of inaugural
moment but through an entire process
becomes aware of who not just what but
who he or she is in relation to what it
is that they're able to produce they
externalize themselves this is something
that Marx picked up on and but many
other people have picked up on as well
even you know to a certain extent the
labor theory of value as we see it in
say Locke Second Treatise where you know
the body is under
it is something that we own we we use
our labor to transform raw materials
into something else we have sort of
externalized
ourselves Locke is under a similar sort
of insight is what Hegel has spelled out
for us so this consciousness that is
driven back into itself though the the
German word there you know the 3m there
you could almost read repression into it
I mean if you wanted to go ahead and
like read read this in relation to
Nietzsche or Freud or whoever else you
like as something like that being
necessary for the development of
consciousness the capacity to to you
know recognize and also miss recognize
oneself to reflect upon oneself go on
ahead because that would not be even
compatible with what Hegel is doing here
just don't assume that's exactly what he
was doing so he says for the subservient
consciousness of such there is two
moments and they separate themselves out
this is a motif that is going to run
throughout the entire the entire part
this third part of self consciousness
that the unhappy self consciousness does
not fully recognize it's what it would
its own what its own activity is
postulating something like a master and
a truly independent self consciousness
as something beyond it something that it
then as a determinate consciousness
exist in relation to the unhappy
consciousness is doing this through a
whole bunch of different transformations
stoicism and skepticism each represents
attempts to to and somehow incorporate
it before that that splitting but there
is a splitting taking place here so he
says these two moments itself as an
independent object and this object is a
mode of consciousness and hence it's
essential nature fall apart the the
servant in this case does realize him or
herself as an independent self
consciousness but they are still within
a social matrix in which domination is
occurring and they these are lose hold
on that and
it flows over to the side of the master
we can say so he said sense however the
form and the being for self are for us
or in themselves the same and since in
the notion the the beginneth of
independent consciousness the intrinsic
being is consciousness the moment of
intrinsic being or thing hood which
we're seeing received its form and being
fashioned that's this part down here
there is no other substance than
consciousness so somehow these two sides
have to be brought back together we can
see that from the vantage point that we
occupy for the consciousness that is
experiencing this that is not that
that's more of a question than an answer
it's a problem rather than a solution
for us we can see the solution because
we're already beyond that so to speak
we're the ones reading this book and
sort of trying to recover it so what we
want to do is feel feel our way and
think our way back into that that early
consciousness and its developments and
feel the sort of anxiety and the
frustration at not having a teen what it
is that it really is searching for so he
goes on and he says what this means is
we are in the presence of
self-consciousness as a new shape like a
shelter this is the what I was talking
about earlier right
we are in the presence of
self-consciousness in a new shape a
consciousness which as the infinitude of
consciousness or is its own pure
movement pure movement we've already
seen this many times is aware of itself
as essential being so what does it mean
to be aware of oneself is essential
being this we've seen can take place in
in multiple waves right self
consciousness can be aware of itself as
an essential being through how it
desires here at this stage self
consciousness will become aware of
itself as an essential being and is a
being who thinks death thank you
in German and Hegel is going to spend a
bit of time here clarifying what that
means for us not entirely there's much
more that has to be worked out here but
there is a fundamental distinction he's
going to make so he says this is a being
which thinks and then the next thing he
says is is very important which is a
free self-consciousness now there's
various modes of freedom available to a
human being many of us identify freedom
was something like living in a
particular society where we're allowed
to do the things that we choose we we
don't even go quite so far as to say
well freedom is the ability to do what
you choose or freedom is you know having
options or something like that we tend
to you know in a rather naive sort of
you know unthinking way just associated
with nobody messing with us and then
we're going to thinking oh if you
actually look at Plato's dialogues there
were people who have that sort of
conception back that freedom can be
understood in other ways however and it
was a very important development of
human consciousness when a freedom was
thought not just in terms of lack of
external people interfering with you or
the capacity to do what it is that you
want you know whether that means having
enough money in the bank to do what you
want or having other subservient to you
so you can impose your will upon them or
you know you know all sorts of other
things here it's being conceptualized as
the capacity to conceptualize as the
ability to think as the ability not just
to think idly to oneself to daydream or
to you know think how to make a million
box or something like that but the
ability to think we might say
philosophically about the big picture
about the huge metaphysical issues what
is what is being what is time what the
hell am I what is the connection between
myself and others these are fundamental
metaphysical issues also moral
to which the being of thanks grapples
with so he says to think does not mean
to be an abstract I it's not just this
sort of you know transcendental critique
purifying things and you know when we
see this also we might think of being
the things oh well doesn't that sound a
lot like you know the Cartesian coach
Ito you saying don't don't go quite
there yet there's something else going
on here to think does not mean to be an
abstract i but an i which has at the
same time the significance of intrinsic
being having its self per object or
relating itself to objective being in
such a way that its significance is the
being for self of the consciousness for
which it is an object there's a long
sentence or what is he saying to think
involves reflexive thinking involves
conceptualizing not only some sort of
external world of objects or aims or
goals that are different than oneself
but also one's own role in the process
so i just you know said don't think
about descartes
but actually you could think about
Descartes insofar as it's not just this
pure seemingly solipsistic withdrawal
from everything else but where the
Curtis saying what am I then a thing
which thinks and what does it mean to
think it means to to assert to deny also
to feel to will to you know imagine all
of those are rolled into the thinking
and insofar as Cartesian philosophy
centered around the reflexivity involved
I can think that I am doing this or in
every act of I think I am grasping
myself in the process in a way that I
can't do with my body forget cart this
would be along the same lines they
current doesn't necessarily keep hold on
Hegel would say so
he says in thinking the object does not
present itself in picture thoughts but
in notions
now what's getting translated there is
picture thoughts is when I put his
representation which is another common
translation
for for shell but Hegel doesn't just say
it's a matter of because it's actually
the plural in the German concepts or
notions and the for stone and Gestalt
in' is also in the the plural to for
strongest element he talks about Gestalt
there does he mean it in the same sense
as shapes of consciousness aren't we
exploring a shape of consciousness right
now wouldn't that be self contradictory
well this is a case where we want to
distinguish between different senses in
which something can be a salt for us can
be a whole unity that is somehow more
than its parts but is still not yet
what Hegel is calling begin if in the
Griffin the guys Ansari in in grasping
things away and conceptualizing in an
active sense not just having concepts
they thrown at you but actually making
them your own you not only make them
your own appropriating them you make
yourself there's in a certain way I
think this will become a little bit more
clear as we look at what else he says he
says in thinking in the notion in a
distinctive being in itself or intrinsic
being consciousness being a media
immediately aware that this is not
anything distinct from itself
what is pictured or figuratively
conceived what immediately is and this
distinction insofar as it is present in
consciousness itself notice he says what
immediately is what's an object for me
and the distinction from myself I'm the
one grasping that distinction that's
what it means to have a sort of
conceptualizing way of thinking images
we can become sort of captivated by
because we don't realize we either
neither the image is totally extrinsic
to us or the image sort of takes us over
all right so he goes I have any
what is pictured or figuratively
conceived would immediately is has such
the form of being something other than
consciousness but a notion is also
something that immediately is in this
distinction insofar as its president of
consciousness and so yes it's
determinate content but since this
content is at the same time accounted
grasped in thought right consciousness
remains immediately aware of its unity
with this determinate and distinct being
not very important contrast not as in
the case of the picture thought where
consciousness still has specifically to
bear in mind that this is it's it's
picture thought there's a certain
arbitrariness to picture thinking or
representation the way Hegel season it's
a it may appear to be universal and it
may indeed be universal it's sort of a
lower case you like say specific to a
particular culture or even universal in
the sense of like you know this is what
the philosophers would say about it
those are abstractions but hey they
would say that's not really
substantively universal it's still sort
of arbitrary it's still tied to
something specific something determinate
he says here we go on the contrary the
notion is from being straightaway my
notion now what is the upshot of this
we're going to come back to this
distinction between representation and
notion plenty of times throughout the
Soviet is that still troubling you don't
worry about this not being the last word
of that what's the upshot of this
there's a certain freedom that comes
with working with the concept even if
the concept does not fully work through
and fully for me most times it's not I
mean I feel if it was we wouldn't need
all these pages we wouldn't have to go
through all these fees on dialectics
there's a freedom that's possessed in in
opposition you might say or by contrast
to working with with mere
representations and this is a freedom
that we can not only think but also in
our being feel this is some
that we can desire this is something
which is going to be at the core of
Stoicism
and of skepticism and of the unhappy
consciousness so he says in thinking I
am free because I am NOT in an other but
remain simply enough solely in communion
with myself and the object which is for
me the essential being is an undivided
unity my being for myself and my
activity in conceptual thinking is a
movement within myself and we've seen
this before right we saw this happen at
the end of several different sections
where consciousness could say yeah all
this stuff has been going on and I've
been like following it along and trying
to make sense of it and what I forgot is
that it's really me who is engaged with
this we saw this you know the perception
the the transition from perception you
know var animal taking the truth of the
object to the understanding and we saw
this at the under force in the
understanding - didn't we there is this
this grasp on the part of self
consciousness that all these things
really are for in thinking we in a
certain sense distance ourself from or
you might say we take the independence
away from these things that in fact do
seem to be confronting us as independent
objects we say they they are for me if
you like you can see we subjective eyes
them not in the sense of they become
subjects but they become something for
us it has subjectivity so he goes out of
thinking I am free right it is essential
however he says in the scare achter
izing this shape of self-consciousness
to bear firmly in mind then it is
thinking consciousness in general that
it's object is an immediate unity of
being in itself and being for itself we
always see Hegel tryna we're always
trying to bring together being in itself
being as grasping what's really real
what's there what substantive and having
that reflexive relation to itself that
being for itself has a reflexive
relation which under which in this case
includes thinking about what it means to
be in itself so he says the Saints the
self same consciousness that repels
itself from itself becomes aware of
itself as the elements of being in
itself but at first it knows itself to
be this element only is a universal mode
in general not as it exists objectively
in the development and process of its
manifold being how should we understand
this last phrase so in this new mode as
consciousness is grasping itself as a
thing that thinks it is grasping itself
in general and for it the more it can
get away from particular determinacy the
specificity of an individuality the more
it's getting to what's essential and
there isn't any any real like what we
might call intersubjectivity here where
it's a concern with the the connection
with the other we've left the Lord you
know in many respects behind in the
world of work and we're going to see as
we move into the next section and talk
specifically about stoicism this is
going to be a first attempt for Hegel
it's not the last way in which
self-consciousness is going to make
sense out of this fact that it is a
being that thinks that is that is
essential to self-consciousness
something is being achieved here but it
is not yeah right now it's mostly
implicit in us being worked out it's
going to get worked out in a determinate
way of being that that recurs at many
points in history but we're still just
at the beginning
you